what's up everyone welcome to simulation
i'm your host atlas
today we are going to be featuring corey
shake what's up
what's up
i love how you say it
it's nice i'm so used to she and like
you know
in white people canadian town but yeah
it's nice
yup gotta get that middle eastern root
shake
yeah
yeah bro
super excited for this i'm also really
grateful for nargis for introducing us
making it happen although we were aware
of each other um she really like bumped
it uh to make it happen which was great
put us in a thread
um got us
about it yeah
yeah it's the the web is connecting
really strongly now
more than ever before this past year
i've noticed you know like people who've
been kind of in the scene for a while
now it's like the webs are just like
really
coming together it reminds me of that
like idea of you know you're only like
one person apart or two people apart or
something like that i don't know i don't
know the quote but like everybody
you're seven links away from anyone on
the planet yeah okay yeah yeah yeah and
i'm seeing that so much now
you know yeah yeah
yeah this also rak razam who is also on
our show
um about
six months ago or so for
maybe the
third or fourth episode together i love
his vibe
he called it the samadhi mesh network
coming online
um
i just i love that or he's also called
it um
galactivation
um
and i just i love all of the ways to
describe it
um
and it can even be simplified to like if
you like
nfts
and you want to find other people that
like nfts it's so easy for you to just
join like discord
channels and watch youtube videos and
find people on twitter
um
but all the way to awakening and waking
up and the people that are waking up
finding each other
another good one from rex
energy is a find the others there are no
others
nice
on a t-shirt you know
that's a t-shirt
yeah for sure
so yeah bro what is up with everything
um behind you you are
um
yeah give us give us the scoop on on um
all that's behind you and then we have
several other um cool threads to pull on
together that i'm feeling
yeah um
well i just started doing
more videos like in this corner i used
to do it in my other corner and it's so
funny because i was really contemplating
this today like in
um just as i was reflecting on this
interview or this talk that we're gonna
have
and we are having and um
it was like the the paradox of like the
ultimate simplicity you know particular
teachings that we come to that are like
timeless
you know like the golden rule let's say
or you know some loud zoo quote or
something like this
and it just kind of like or a zen cone
it just kind of like stops the mind and
you know it it's it's it's or even just
on instagram like be yourself you know
like it's such an entry-level idea but
it's actually like the supreme you know
and so
i have this other poster over there
that's like
live your dream create your happiness
like a typical like you know get at
walmart or something
all the like real basic level quotes on
this cute little thing
so i usually there and then i was
reflecting on the idea of just like the
ultimate simplicity and then like on the
other end maybe like the ultimate
complexity which is a lot of what this
work is which comes from um the chaonic
science freedom teaching work which is
some of the original or more expanded
law of one teachings and um
you know
i know you guys are into the law of one
um
channelings and things and you know they
give a a lot of really beautiful
components to
you know i guess we could say maybe the
teachings of all time or you know the
teachings of the cosmos
and then when you get in chaolantics and
freedom teachings this is like you know
it's kind of like love one on steroids
in my view like it's like all the
mechanics it's all the advanced light
body you know uh systems and
um the the real deep like quantum
science behind ascension and behind
incention and behind um our bioregenesis
which is our healing process you know
so it's just funny because yeah like i'm
you know like you know you go through
the path of non-duality or yana and it
brings you to such a supreme simplicity
that
you you essentially become that
simplicity but the funny thing in the
paradox is you become that simplicity
but that's that's actually the doorway
to then live this like
like you know just wild the wildest
complexity you could ever you know you
can't even conceive right and that's a
lot of what a lot of this is and you
know post realization at least from what
people typically say you know about
ayanna awakening or something like this
i i that's when i really got into more
of the more complexity and advanced
elements while still rested in a lot of
that you know these kind of like simple
pieces because to me that's really what
life is it can be really simple you know
um and it's best that way i find because
you're you're not so overwhelmed versus
previous times in my life when i got
into a lot of this you know it was just
so overwhelming it was like reading the
most advanced like quantum physics
textbook that i had no like i'm like i
can't do this you know
um
so you know so it's been many years that
i've been involved in this and it's it's
basically just like in in the simplest
way to put it it's basically looking at
like a very high level or advanced level
of buddhist teachings like light body
buddhist teachings um we could say like
tibetan dojin or vadriana you know
getting into all the different forms of
light bodies because there's many
different forms
and um really just the eternal you know
because
much of my path especially in the yana
the yana path and you know coming into a
realization this
my questions were often like what's
after enlightenment like it's i'm not
gonna just like end like live in a blob
of nothing you know what i mean like
what's
like what's after it that's constantly
what was coming and
so i found like realization was really
just the doorway to eternity it was like
the opening to the eternal
and
now getting into all this kind of stuff
it's
yeah it's just uh it's tumbling i feel
like that's probably the best term to uh
describe it yeah
i like how you share
on both of those sides of the spectrum
where
you
can have a mainstream
[Music]
simplicity like the delphic maxim of uh
know thyself
or even the other ones like uh
like surety brings ruin or nothing in
excess which are like very common
delphic maxims um
maybe even the most prominent or salient
ones the ones that were written at the
top of the temple of apollo at delphi
and those like really resonate with
mainstream um
and
you could spend
a lot of time like inquiring into those
but at the same time you can really
relate to the simplicity of them or even
yeah the direct path pointings of lao
tza or of buddha
or of some of the sufi metaphysic um
there's so many like direct ones i and
my father are one also in the abrahamics
um
and
and that those can like really
like hit and be like quite like simple
but then you have the mathematics behind
you
that also
of course quantum mechanically represent
such complexity and we really feel that
in this like emergence theory of how uh
sentience sort of arises in this
universal creation and then sort of like
wakes up to itself and then
um
and then does the dance and explores
infinite potential
but at the same time when we look at it
we can say actually it's so simple like
the complexity behind you also boils
down to simplicity and there's like
that's the simultaneity of having
something that is both simple and
complex at the same time and you can
sort of play with it um
in any of those expressions across
across that spectrum so i like that
share
and then i feel like asking you also
this has been become one of my favorite
questions to tune into on the show
is
when we talk about waking up or
awakening or abiding awakening so when
it's a
moment-to-moment direct experience
what do you
say that is
um
what was coming to me today when i was
just like sitting on myself it was like
just being with everything you know or
first it was being with everything then
it was being everything
more directly you know
because if everything is it already
then it's never not been it because if
ever if it's always been it or if it is
it then it's never not been it always
will be it you know when we're speaking
of like the absolute nature god source
which is often the term i use
um
the true reality natural reality
um
if everything is it already everything's
uh not even a manifestation of it it's
just everything is it directly as it
then
we
can only we only could have ever been
that
and of course it's just the ideas that
we've held the conditioning the traumas
you know the many distortions to our dna
over the multi-billion year you know
angelic human history it was very long
um
you know the working through all that we
could say is the the quote-unquote path
you know a lot of non-dualists will say
well there's no path you know of course
right there's no there's no path there's
no practice whatever
but
in truth they're both
they're both real they're both um
like when we look at the teachings like
say the golden rule
the golden rule to me like treat another
as you desire to be treated that is the
most entry-level spiritual teaching of
them all in my view right
and it's also the most supreme
like it's the highest teaching and it's
the most it's like non-duality in
perfect form
so
that teaching and
you know an amalgamation of others i
find are we just briefly briefly um
because this is this is getting
fantastic i would just like to briefly
check in on the golden rule itself
because
um treating others the way you would
like to be treated i've also heard it um
sort of shifted
um into something more like uh just
treating um
all with love to or you know that type
of right um
because if one wants to be treated in a
you know and then you're treating people
in the way that you want to be treated
but that's of a like you you actually
don't mind it when people are mad or
upset or
physically
you know that type of thing um so how do
you feel about that rephrasing and then
continue onward with what with what you
were saying
yeah well there was so many combinations
it's like you see that golden rule like
dial with all the religions and then
it's like it was shared in different
ways through all of them and there's one
there's different ones that resonate
more but i do like that because i feel
like it is just a representation of
divine love you know
and true compassion god's compassion
and i feel like the only way but that's
the funny part right is
the only way that you can come to know
that compassion is if you've come to
realize the true nature where there is
no other you know there is no separate
self
you know
because then you see well yeah of course
it's only this love you know
and so
so coming back to the idea of being
everything um i feel it's this it's that
simultaneity of
both being everything and being nothing
at the same time like a typical like
nettie nettie you know nettie nancy not
this not that and then also i am
designed that you know the divine love
one side
so to me like if we're going to put it
the simplest way i feel like it's both
of those happening simultaneously all
the time like that's beautiful
yeah beautiful brother yes
yeah keep going i'm loving it and then
i'll hit the ball back with this no
that's i mean
because there's so many ways to describe
it and
um
and i mean i've described it in
different ways you know i've written
about the absolute source you know it's
not this it's not that but yet it's
everything you know it's it's not god
it's not compassion it's not universe
it's not all these things it can't even
be named there's nothing you can really
say to it but yet it's still known and
it can be known through the simplest of
moments and the most complex of you know
grand experiences
but in truth it's it's this simultaneous
knowing that
yeah there's a complete emptiness
complete absolute empty that cannot be
conceived by any mind no word can touch
it and yet that is also simultaneously
soulful you know with like the depth of
love and compassion and you know often
we found that in the previous traditions
where some being would you know realize
it would be like an integration process
and after that integration would often
be communicated as a dropping in the
heart or dropping into compassion
right and if that didn't occur if that
complete awakening didn't occur that's
often why you found gurus finding
themselves in sticky situations because
the compassion wasn't being what what
the the movement into the body the
movement into the integration of all the
chakras of all the aspects of self so
that that gentle simple compassion
golden rule or divine love
is then realized and manifested you know
within the walking reality in the
simplest of moments right
um
and so
so that's been much of
you know what's what it's been for me
you know over the past few years is just
being humbled again and again and again
to this this compassion this love and
maybe you know it's different for a
female body too i don't know but i know
for as a male body that it was kind of a
different it was like this you know
empty nothingness but you know these
like the kind of i wouldn't say
hierarchical but
it was it was a bit of a different ride
before compared to now where
it's like yeah again just endless
humility endless compassion endless
gentleness like moving deeper into that
purity and that innocence
so
so yeah so that's my best way of
describing it and i feel like maybe in a
couple years will be different but i
feel like you know keep it as simple as
possible
yeah and i love the coin analogy
uh one side being nothing and the other
side being everything
and then the you could even say the
superposition or the entanglement of
those two and also being something at
the same time
um where there is the appearance of the
cory and the atlas expressions having a
conversation but underneath it is truth
source yeah
yes yes because you know often i guess
in dual tradition there's a lot of
speaking to the idea like oh there's
nobody here there's no doer there's a
thinker
and yet but if we get more direct more
more specific if everything is the
absolute reality then there is also a
doer and i think
it can be both right like it's just that
the integration of a higher identity is
more accurate in my experience right
where i i have felt progressively
post realization that there has been a
higher identity that has now
you could say almost come into the body
you know like it's like that's what
speaks that's what acts that's what
moves everything is that and sure we
could say yes that is the god self
um but there's still this individualized
expression so
i always laugh when
people get a bit too attached to that
teaching because
it's true but then the opposite is also
true if everything's absolutely it then
it's both you know so yeah this is funny
and actually when we approach it from a
simultaneity i feel like it's most
direct path
so
even for mainstream to
be able to as an entry point recognize
how like two sides of the same coin of
like
the
political left and the political right
in like the united states or in
several of the developed countries
um where there's a conservative and a
liberal that those are so entangled or
intertwined or simultaneous they're
dependent they're codependently arising
on each other
it can be a good entry point for also
consciousness and physicalism as another
one
for the simultaneity of that
that there is the appearance of the
phone but the phone itself is dependent
on perception is dependent on
consciousness or awareness on that
arising just like when you take the
screen itself and the screen is just
like
consciousness just like awareness and
then there is this apparent modulation
of it where you go oh
there's an arising of neo and then boop
a passing of that thought or sensation
or experience whatever and it doesn't
have to tie to a sense of self-image
that's what gets de-conditioned or
deconstructed
where every single sensation or
experience gets tied to a self-image
and then there's always this seeking
energy that wants to extract peace and
happiness from the external
um and there's a total deconditioning of
that and then the nature is seen as
inherent peace and happiness um as
inherent empty fullness also
um
and then it's a lived experience i think
this point is so so so overlooked and so
important um
but it's
like frank yang again one of
my close friends as well as one of
arguably one of the greatest
inquirers into the nature and
communicators of it
um
talks about it like a contemplative
fitness ai that's constantly running in
the background
and that
there's nothing left but the continuous
recognition
and then it life becomes saturated you
also called it divine love this divine
love is present
and it's felt in every breath that's
felt in every
sip of water by the food um
every eye contact
um
and and then that's emanated like the
sun and that's enlightenment the
emanation
of that and then it
it
it creates catalysts like the one
creates catalysts on itself when it
emanates like that and so um that's
that's still fullness
um
that still flame that's still light um
can generate a lot of um powerful
ripples and
um more so really than
than uh than anything else yet it's so
important to not become
boring
it's i've noticed that that's that's the
case so deeply um
that there's like a
pacification
of
the spiritual
uh athlete or warrior or
olympic of consciousness that
there's just a
there's like a forgetting of the
empowerment side or forgetting of the
paintbrush basically
like
like bruh like go all out
go
all out express yourself fully as the
one um and like do cool [ __ ] be [ __ ]
interesting be gangster as [ __ ]
um
at the same time that you know that
none of this is real and yet it's also
appearing as it is um
and so you can do both at the same time
and so never ever lose that also the
simultaneity of those two things like
one eye all the way back
nirvana
and the other eye
constantly creating
constantly
paint brushing
um
and
and out of a selfless
place out of a pure place
um
and that's the divine creatorhood
because that's well that's what gave
rise to the entire creation is that
frequency and so like to toss that is
like just boringness
yeah
yeah well
the piece you said about like the the
way i've defined it is kind of like
yeah the the no self ideas is more so
the idea that like there's nothing there
to take ownership over everything and
another way that i've experienced it or
it's happened is um uh like the brakes
are off that's kind of a good way of
describing you know there's there's no
you know there's no brakes anymore and
that's been yeah past four or five years
like no brakes no brakes so
it it it's that's that's the integration
you know it's like it's all the traumas
all the all the inter inner workings of
the being
are kind of like reformulating and
because there's no breaks it's
inevitable that you start to balance
that
um for me it's been kind of like very
much the monk path and then on the other
side you know the yeah entrepreneur and
out there and creative and doing all the
stuff right
and so like the the apparent dichotomy
or difference between the two continues
to just
it should be shown that that is also of
course not separate and it's taken time
for me you know i feel it's an
integration process and maybe very
different for everybody um but i know
like for my journey because i've been
more um on the you know celibate monk
fasting minimalism you know that type of
like lifestyle
uh for so long that the integration into
the creative component was was sparking
the whole time you know past like 10 12
14 years but again when those breaks are
off then it's like inevitable that
you just you can't not you cannot move
in that creative way
um and a good example of that was uh
doing that drive fast last week i
couldn't stay still like if i stayed
still for too long like my my my
everything would cramp i would get kind
of grumpy like my whole body was just
not feeling it you know and so even
though
i have you know i'm not eating or
drinking for whatever 10 days but it's
like i still have to move i'm still
going on like five 10 kilometer walks
i'm still creating i'm still do because
it just ca it was like the most
beautiful reminder that
in the natural state
which is always there but in the dry
fast it's just like a more of a kick in
the ass
um
you can't stop moving like the m the
universe is constant change constant
constant movement you know so if you get
into that space where it's like
yeah like the you know typical stuff
you're talking about like whatever the
nothingness or you know attachments
nothingness or something um it's just
not possible like you just it just won't
it won't happen you know for that long
at least
so
so i definitely feel you on that for
sure and i think that's what's
that's i i appreciate that a lot about
the female a lot of the female teachers
around um um a lot more because a lot of
them maybe haven't had a meditative path
or they haven't explored that that other
side of things as much not always but
it's common especially in rg maybe um
and it's just it's fascinating to me
because i i feel that within myself but
it wasn't necessarily my my path but
post integration it's so certainly been
that and it's just it's yeah it's
amazing it's amazing
yeah i love that i love how you share
the two sides of the coin in this
example where you have
the
the clear
cessation of linking
sensation sensation and experience to a
sense of self uh self-image
um
and then
there's the
other side of the coin which i love how
you described which is the the foot is
fully on the gas pedal
creatorhood
um
and
um i love that and it resonates so so
deeply um
and
i feel like
the matrix or the mainstream um
which
we could just simply define as just
people
that are
in the patterns of governments and
economies and the mass media and
the money supply
and
um
i'm not inquiring into the only question
that matters which is what is i
and one of the first
big shifts
out of that
is
what you could say is the embodiment of
more of the
divine creatorhood
so
like when somebody gets the urge to like
be empowered and go on a hero's journey
or pursue entrepreneurship
that type of stuff
and so they do usually put their foot on
the gas pretty [ __ ] hard and like go
at that
and then there's usually like a question
about like well
what's happiness though or like what is
peace um
and then there's the inquiry process
that usually comes up which is the what
is i
um
which can be very logical it can also be
very meditative in its experiences of
samadhi and that very deep absorption
into unity um in the
disattachment of
of attaching sensation and experience to
to self
um
and so i love that i love that because
then that's where more and more of the
emptiness the nothingness the shunyata
the no selfness
um
that's where more and more of that can
blossom which is in many cases a i've
found to be
um
a later stage of awakening um
i've noticed not only with frank but
with several others in um
in sort of stages or steps of awakening
there's the simultaneity of of this
already being it with itself and that
being impossible to have any levels or
or uh
stages because it is already with itself
in a conversation here and that is what
we're talking about source with itself
just playing with itself here
in a universe
as these conscious agents talking to
itself like there's just no
there's no
it's just front and back of hand and
then
um
yet simultaneously there is the apparent
levels or or stages where as we
experience we can only talk about this
retroactively which is also so
interesting um
like
we without a doubt couldn't talk about
this 10 years ago no chance um because
we were still baked into separation um
and we're still baked into self-hood
selfing
um
and i've i found that a lot of the stage
and i'll really curious if this is
similar for you but i found that a lot
of the
um
i found a lot
of spirituality um does seem to end at
awareness or consciousness
um
which i do feel is in many ways um
super helpful like those pointings of
course because i feel like it it um goes
to
um the first stage which is shifting out
of ego to uh to consciousness to
awareness and being like what the [ __ ]
um
like is this really consciousness
talking to itself and then there's like
the trans personalization or the
impersonalization
the universalization
um
into like an infinite consciousness
which then appears as like oh i'm gonna
i'm gonna transcend the duality even
between
consciousness and object
and then that's the merging of
consciousness and physicalism to
capitalist self or god everything being
that
very oceanic
[Music]
and then then this is sort of where i
feel like many people for sure like that
one is already higher level um but that
i would say this next one is the
investigation into no self basically
it's the investigation into the nature
of sensation and experience and
attaching that into self-image and it's
more like a it's more like an olympic
athlete's approach to it it's it's like
someone that's basically
turned on the nature of sensation
experience and it's
how it automatically creates a sense of
self and how you can obliterate or
dissolve that by inquiry um
and then that's sort of what i found to
be what creates the natural
natural state
which
feels a lot more
spontaneous
free
and very clearly like awake to all those
levels and yet transcending them at the
same time and that's been triangulated
now for
almost a year now um by
several people that i've been talking to
that are some of the most awake people
that i know as well as now myself more
and more via direct experience and so
how do you feel about the stages
um
how do you feel about the levels
and it's obviously it's clear that we
both feel the simultaneity of there
being none and yet also the appearance
of there being some so how do you feel
about that as some sort of like a staged
or a um
a systematized way for us to um
recognize how the one wakes up to itself
yeah well thanks for sharing that yeah i
mean i do uh resonate with the the gist
of that
that um
that expression and i've heard it often
you know from a lot of these other
teachers to
my previous teacher ramaji who i
received a transmission from had a
similar uh kind of concept of moving
through
um note self well it was a bit different
it was more initially no self then it
was god's self then it was kind of back
to himself a little bit again almost and
then there's this absolute kind of
simultaneity that emerges and that's um
pretty accurate to how i um
kind of
journaled and you know reflected on my
own process
um through that system
and then kind of like what i alluded to
before because
you know
when i when i
when i tuned to the nature of just well
it's not tuned it's just like it's
always here
um and there's a there's always this
hereness of this simultaneity and it's
so simple it's so easy it's like
unmovable you know there's a clear
unmovable nature that previous in my
experience i was not uh aware of at
least we could say you know um so
there's that unmovable mountain-like
knowing that is there
and
and yet at the same time uh especially
coming into the chaonic work
um where they're presenting you know
this eternal life perspective you know
this eternal essentially this eternal
ascension
where
what we've come to know as enlightenment
on this path in my view is is kind of
like
the beginning of eternity you know it's
like it's like this doorway into
it's it's almost like we were so we're
so like baby-like and child like that we
thought we thought enlightenment was
like this big thing and then we come to
realize enlightenment then we realize oh
wait a minute
like now it's just like here we go
you know and that's that's more and more
where the humbling for me has been
because
coming into to these studies um
although i would you know i was coming
from this place of this clear knowing
that like like frank says like yeah
there's it's like there's no more you
can go like you you there's what
distance you know like where where are
you to head what more are you to realize
from this knowing and yet
even while that is accurate there's
still this clarity that um
well now yeah we're exploring the the
the eternal space of creation which
certainly does have many more levels
many many more levels um in regards to
dimensional uh frequency accretion in
regards to
uh frequency flows like for instance
what people typically term as kundalini
would on a 15 dimensional scale would go
from dimensions one to
nine
then we have maharata frequency which is
the christ frequency which is from 10 to
12. then we have kirashay right 13 and
50. then you have kunda ray which is
beyond that so
these frequencies
um are each different you know so even
though i you know i went through the
whole kundalini thing and then you have
this awakening and then there's this
abidence
there's still all these flavors that i i
came to know and it's very accurate and
depicted in
um buddhist culture where
buddha was saying one thing about light
bodies and then other other masters were
saying another thing about rainbow body
and other light bodies golden lotus but
like there was all these different
flavors to how the exploration could
still evolve
um
and and so so so that's where i i come
at it from where yeah like and i
i kind of view it like um
after there was kind of an abundance it
was almost like a honeymoon i felt like
i didn't care about practices i didn't
care about anything i didn't do anything
i just for months i would i was going
back to the clubs i was going out and
eat all this stuff i hadn't eaten a
while i was watching movies for the
first time you know because i i was such
like a monk for so long
um you know or so devoted to my my
business so i was just like monk life
business and just like you know
so i had this like honeymoon but then
after that honeymoon it was kind of like
oh yeah like now it's it's this eternal
space to explore right and like even
this diagram here this is a breakdown of
the 12 dimensional time make sure it's
right so we have uh earth which is right
here right a higher version of earth is
called tara dimension five
is actually dimension eight right lyra
dimension 12 right
so for instance if we were to look at
that from the standpoint of okay
we we we've attained this realization
here on this dimension
but there is a reason why our bodies are
not
in these different other ranges
right simultaneously we could say well
there is a reason why that's that's the
case and i feel like that's the further
unfoldment in evolution that actually
just naturally happens almost you could
say spontaneously even
right like like to me
of course not everyone needs to get into
all this stuff to me it's just
fascinating people could have these
activations and awareness um just on
their own you know just naturally like
you people who just wake up and then all
of a sudden they're waking up to
themselves in some other dimension i
feel like it's just it can be just a
spontaneous thing
but um but yeah i'm i'm quite clear and
just kind of
i just love the simultaneity of that
because i feel like it actually is is um
it's the true to me it's it's it's the
it's been the humility right it's like
yeah sure i i feel like there's this
clarity of of uh abidence and you know
and
uh
a non-dual awakening and all these kind
of terms and yet at the same time it's
like this
it's like this
uh
i don't know how to describe the
humility it's like you can't even put
words to it you know how how
um eternal everything is in every
direction
you know like even some you know
spiritual yana folks i'll start talking
about like
billionaire angelic human human history
right because kehlanic science in
particular they have the ascension
mechanics on one side and then the other
side they have the like the most
mind-blowing history of the universe you
can probably find on planet right now
and you know a lot of the ghana people
are not not interested you know i think
they don't want to hear some of that
stuff right and it's fine
it's just funny to me but but my
perspective is like well if you if you
are saying that everything's eternal and
you realize the infinite then it means
infinite in every direction
everything is infinite every every angle
is infinite the histories the
conspiracies the the entrepreneurial
path you know everything in every
direction so if you still have these
ideas like well yana is this you know
nirvana is this but then there's still
kind of no i'm not that's not it you
know like uncom uncompromising
non-duality which i love
but to me it's like well it's it's a
turn in every direction so like let's
let's play with it all you know so it's
just um
yeah i just laughed it's just been funny
to me to observe and
and in myself because i i
i i was very much like this you know i
didn't uh wasn't open to a lot of things
at times and even even after abidence
you know there was still like you know
or whatever but
i think it's an endless humbling
i think that's what true that's what
awakening is you just get humbled so so
so many times you can't eat like
yeah
yeah
okay yeah
happy
january 11th 1 11 at 11 11
p.m
oh well it was amazing yeah it's a
beautiful beginning of our brotherhood
yeah
yeah it feels really good and i would
love to also
play on
ascension mechanics that was cool um i
also would like to play a little bit
more um together on on fasting um as
we've
um we're both very interested in that um
you're like a an olympic
athlete though in it which is very cool
so let's um let's play on ascension
mechanics for now
um
so
there is obviously a
way that this dance
unfolds with itself
and it appears to be like
sentience or consciousness uh waking up
to its unity after falling asleep to
separation
[Music]
and
i would love to hear more about how
you
[Music]
understand the ascension mechanics
because to me it feels
very much
like
a
the one waking up to itself and through
the illusion of separation through the
you could say the veil of surveiller
gateless gate which
as we talked about which is
that we are always already source and
yet we've also apparently forgotten
ourselves as that and then remembered
um
so when you say ascension mechanics do
you mean that or what are you talking
about specifically
pretty much i mean the
like as a brief history the the essence
of the chaonic science freedom teachings
transmissions were basically
a
group of teachings that would be
translated at particular times in our
history
um within generally a an ascension cycle
uh or um you know a starfire cycle so
this this cycle cellular activation
cycle that we're in right now is from
2000 2017
and so what tends to happen is there
will be particular speakers
there are individuals who get the
contracts to come and scribe in these
teachings so they're basically teachings
that are held on uh
holographic discs called this cloister
door to our plates and these are like
the teachings of all times every
tradition on the planet basically has
come from these teachings and when you
get into them you see the crossovers
everywhere it's like everywhere
so mind-blowing
yeah so
mind-blowing those crossovers between
the traditions insane yes yes uh-huh
that's it so
so yeah so um the the original path of
ascension was generally where we would
go through stargates there's 12 on the
planet they're in different places in
the on the planet and usually the path
of ascension is you'd go through those
stargates and you would go up into some
of these higher worlds but because of
the histories and the very dark history
actually of this planet that plan was
changed and we basically
we're basically more in in this path of
incention which is actually i feel like
a lot of people tune in naturally like
this idea that we're moving almost like
inward within ourselves and the whole
universe is within ourselves and we can
essentially create our own stargate to
go wherever we'd like to go or go home
you know because we may have a home
outside of this time matrix outside of
this universe and a different star or
some other place
um but we're basically re re accessing
and remembering the divine blueprint or
the template which is another term for
uh we could say the anatomy of god
because we could say like when we get
into mathematics or like geometries
sound frequencies we can see that
everything has a divine blueprint and
structure and that's why we naturally
want to love then kill that's why we
naturally want to like you know
like all the things we just like things
grow you know we walk forwards rather
than backwards like there's this natural
blueprint and structure that
like again when the self that no self is
there then we just follow that natural
blueprint most of the time you know just
kind of all naturally happens very very
beautifully
so
the remembrance of the divine blueprint
is essentially the reintegration of our
expanded in this case 15 dimensional
self and it's really eternal but if we
just start there
um into this present moment awareness
right so the the typical yana teaching
of the awakening to god's self i mean
generally when someone's there like the
amount of epiphanies and insights and
visions and all the things that are
happening every day it's like you're
living years within a day you know
because you're perpetually remembering
everything all the time like you know
all a lot of the blocks are are kind of
um dissolving
and so that's that's very
accurately actually how i've experienced
this because even though for me like i
don't always understand a lot of the
deep quantum physics stuff or all the
sciency stuff or i have no interest
maybe you know it's not i don't it
doesn't feel like it's irrelevant at a
particular time but sometimes even just
seeing these codes you know recognizing
like this code is a part of our anatomy
you know like this is actually me
just like this the spirit body you know
this is the light body mechanic right so
when you look at some of these codes
you're actually seeing yourself again
and it and it and it sparks that so
initially it may just be like a code
you're looking at the wall
but then over time all of a sudden it
just activates and you literally feel it
like you literally feel this this
structure this this living organic
breathing structure that's the most like
beautiful like
you know beautiful beautiful uh
i don't know how to describe it like
it's just every it's everything you
could imagine about you know you know
you go on these psychedelic trips and
you have all these images and so imagine
now like you know you're you're sober
and you're here and you're connected
itself and now you've actually can feel
this living structure
that's that's the integration of of what
these mechanics have have uh been for me
because it's just been a further
remembrance you know and and then when
we're you know often in all traditions
there will be three main important
elements right they'll be generally the
geometries the mathematics the sound
frequencies and the energy intention
right like the commandments the virtues
you know like acting with right action
you know like these kind of core
components to our conduct
and all three in combination have been
for me the remembrance of my own divine
blueprint like when i if i'm chanting
particular tones
i'm i'm you know because if we look at
it from a post-realization perspective
pre-realization everything is for
seeking you know i'm gonna do this
mantra and i'm gonna get there i'm gonna
get there you know
but if we look at it from from more
practical like okay
if i chant this tone
it's going to activate this particular
thing right like just like if i want to
sign a piece of paper i use a pencil or
a pen you know like and i signed the
paper so it becomes just very like what
it is like very practical not oh you
know i'm doing this mantra and i gotta
get some you know that's the core um
shift that i felt you know because i
love still chanting and working with a
lot of these style you know of son or
geometries because it activates certain
currents of frequency
that helps me further remember myself
you know and
and and you know frank's talk about this
too a lot of people have you know you
start activating various cities or start
having recall past lives or you're able
to see auras or all these things kind of
happen not because they need to
but because that's just you remembering
and seeing starting to see through the
fog
and like particularly past lives you
know it's taking me a long time but now
starting to actually see them and you
know go and remember myself like you
know sitting in meditation in an ashram
or something like and actually
viscerally like experiencing it like man
that's like fun stuff right like what
else is there to do you know
that's how i look at it right
um
so
so yeah and this one you can't really
see like i really like this one because
this is the called the virtues the 12
virtues and um you know basic stuff love
compassion you know integrity
communication you know these basic
principles but this diagram
is actually the structure it is actually
held as a structure within our anatomy
you can't really see it but it's
literally like the actual structure of
our anatomy so
you want something off the wall and show
it to us
yeah be cool
this is called the um
the wheel of the virtues or the the
mandalic mandalic shield
right it's uh it's also called it's also
from the shield of kalei
so this comes from a certain council of
beings called the mashayana
and the mashayana is also a similar term
to messiah which which is the term for
messiah but masaya was a different
spelling and mashayana is a bit of a
different spelling obviously um but
they're the elemental they're the
elemental kingdom the elemental benders
earth crystal which is together air fire
water
ether and so
this um mandalic shield and the funny
thing you know like obviously in
buddhism you have mandalas this is
spelled um
m-a-n-d-h-a-l-i-c so it's very similar
but you know again the crossovers
um but that that's been such a powerful
tool for me because
post realization i was really focused
and i was endlessly being humbled to
just like the basic qualities of my
human experience you know like acting
with more integrity more respect more
compassion
you know um i don't know being on time
for things like community like just all
the stuff like basic stuff of human life
that was naturally like revealing
and then when when you know i came into
stuff like this or i was going back into
old buddhist stuff after
um i was recognizing as you know these
aspects of like my actual anatomy like
just like my finger is a part of my
anatomy
the quotient of energy that i've
assimilated of compassion or integrity
or these things is actually like a part
of my anatomy that i'm remembering
and in in the times where the stargate
passages would would be open
um depending on where you're going you
actually have to have a certain quotient
of these virtues
cultivated within your anatomy within
your your frequency within your being
for you to be able to even pass through
a certain stargate
right so
um so i find that for a lot of people
post realization this stuff happens
anyways you know it's just it's natural
but for me i'm pretty intellectual in
this regard so i i it's fascinating to
me you know to understand stuff and
again like what else
what else am i gonna do with my time
right
but uh
yeah so
whoa so yeah okay i want to pull on the
thread of
what you said was
the
the
holographic disc
is that right yeah
so
so
a
which we could maybe also call what some
spirituality calls the akashic records
different different
um the these these discs are actually
physical plates that can be materialized
and i believe some of them are here on
planet but they're they're nowhere to be
found you know i'm not going to find
them
but generally they are um
multi-dimensional so the main speaker
ashayana dean who's now called iaesha
she was speaker one um she was um uh the
one who was the main scribe for this
teachings and
um there was two others uh speakers
originally there's always three that'll
incarnate together
um and
you know and of course i'm just a
messenger for these teachings like you
know there's all that stuff is for other
research if you want to get deeper but
what i can to when it comes to the
holographic this is yeah they can't take
physical form
but often they're in a holographic form
and
the speaker generally will be trained
from a very young age as ashayana was
and she'll be trained by the higher
guardian councils that assist in the
translation of those holographic discs
um but the training consists of her
being able to go and actually read the
discs like you would a like a textbook
but the core of these cdd plates were
responsible for what we call the
maharata texts which is the same term or
very similar terms of the mahabharata
text in the hindu tradition
but the maharaja texts were the original
i think 512 books
uh textbooks and those were yeah the
original teachings of the law of one
um and uh
and yeah so
they basically in many ways they build
off the higher levels of adriana buddhas
but they add many different layers to
what that presented um
and
um asiana is a reincarnate of a fairly
well-known master i forget the name but
i mean there's so many of them and um
there's a couple other beings there's
quite a few beings actually in the
community and i'm i'm always hesitant
going into that too much but
uh but yeah so
it's pretty interesting i mean i've been
very humbled by that group of that body
of work
and if we can get a little bit um
more clear
is the
channeling
or access to the holographic disc in
this case
um this is sort of access to the
the
essence of source and how it expresses
itself
essentially yeah and that the channeling
was more accurately it was more
more so data streaming as they like to
call they're actually not advocates in
the system of channeling because it can
be very damaging to the template you
know basically possession channeling is
just a fancier term for possession right
and i've done i've done that and i had a
lot of spontaneous experiences of that
when i was working with psychedelics and
many years ago and i had to do a lot of
healing from that you know so they're
pretty they're more specific on data
streaming which is different in the
sense that you're streaming from
basically a higher version of self you
know a higher dimensional version of
yourself
um
versus
allowing someone else to come into the
body you know which is yeah can be kind
of kind of risky i guess you could say
especially especially in this planet
because this planet's uh yeah it's
an interesting one
i like the way you describe that which
is that
it's
so deeply just tuned into one's nature
which is already here which is we could
say the essence of source expressing
itself or even just higher self which is
really
that
and coming from that place now so
instead of coming from the conditioning
and the separation and the lack beliefs
instead coming from
a place of total sourcefulness and total
emptiness of self-interest and
self-image and total service to creation
and weakening
that's so deeply resonant and it feels
it feels like
having access to
[Music]
myself capital s
so true like so much like
i love that and it's just like
it is like just such high alignment um
in just what's present there is this
this indescribable
freedom and this indescribable love um
yeah
yeah even yeah even more more words just
end up you know because those like those
even just the you know the feeling and
like the of of that you know we want the
feeling of it you know you know bentino
talks about it so much like you want the
feeling you want the frequency or the
vibration the moment-to-moment
experience of freedom and love not the
concept of it
and to like radiate that um
it's so so good to radiate out just
emptiness of self and emptiness of self
image in pure service for creation
awakening to itself
um ah
and like feeling it feeling that
um and and that does feel like the
highest when when a dude tune in like
that's
that's really it and
the shift to that on a moment-to-moment
experience and then surrounding
ourselves like in the triple gem
sangha
surrounding ourselves a spiritual
community surrounding ourselves with
other awake expressions so that we can
get reflected when we're like
like getting a bit into lack or
separation or whatever it is
it's been so important and that's why
we're building no limit society
and it's
such a joy
to see how fractal-like it is really
it's so
deeply fractal-like because you know
exactly where i was a year ago
i'm just
you know talking to my other selves that
are there now
um
it's so deeply fractal-like and then in
a year then they'll be talking to their
other selves that are where they are at
now
uh
yeah and and it's such an inner job
really it's such an inner job to
come from
that vibration come from that frequency
from that
purity from that emptiness of self and
self image
and of that energy of stewardship
shepherding service
um
and
and just feeling the love and the
freedom
it's such an inner job to have that
moment to moment and to basically
basically
be like
someone is
with a gun
just following you around all the time
ready to pull the trigger on the back of
your head when you forget
to come from that
yeah
yeah yeah it's true and then and it's
and it's like um
yeah i mean
in every moment you know like the
simplest of moments like smiling at the
stranger you know like i don't know
petting the dog like loving the dog
making a nice meal for a friend or
something you know just the simplest of
moments where
um
again if you're feeling the embodiment
within like every cell of your body
essentially you know like then yeah
everything can everything is extravagant
already so
like everything is redeemed you know
like everything is redeemed from
whatever we originally thought it was
whether it's boring or mundane or this
or that you know because because i feel
like if we start there
or if it's not even we start it's going
to happen there anyways then all like
the bigger things that we think we're
going to accomplish or create or
manifest
it just i mean it becomes so much more
focused you know
100
yeah
and how much better is it when we come
from the emptiness of self and self
image and how much more better is it
when we come from
the purity of already being free already
being love with itself
and creating from that whole
place
uh is so good it's
because then everything that is created
is created from a sense of the whole and
from a sense of service and from love
and
that's
so much different than the vibration
that's polluted even even slightly but
most of the time it's with a lot
of
lack
of separation of self-image
um
because then it doesn't become about the
the nothing and the everything it
becomes about
what can i
in my body
get
um
and that's just so
like you guys you can't get more direct
than this
like
we just can't like this is it
this is as direct as it's going to get
it's going to keep evolving and waking
up to itself and getting more and more
precise
but this is really the peak of what's
available right now it's basically the
synthesis of all
of the wisdom traditions
and the distillation of them like as
accurately as possible in the merging of
that with science and with
entrepreneurship and with shifting the
mainstream into
awakening like there's just nothing more
precise right now and so tune into this
like above everything else
tune into this
and then this
has
sri aurobindo and the mother mural fossa
call it the well of honey under the rock
and it's always there
this freedom and this
and this love are always there and the
rock is separation the rock is
is lack um and
the rock is the sense of lower case s
self and tying everything to that
um and this is it guys like this is the
most direct that you can get because
it's the simultaneity of there
always already being the honey but at
the same time the well of honey but also
at the same time noticing how to
dissolve the layers that have built up
which are the rock
yeah the brakes are off you know the
brakes are off the brakes are all
be with every be everything be
everything
be everything
yeah it's a welcoming it's an endless
welcoming you know i'm constantly
reminded of like when
we speak to this divine blooper and it's
no different than say like the yogic
divine blueprint
you know like yoga you have devotion and
yana and bhakti and you know
[Music]
all these different forms but it's like
they're all like they're all just the
fractal of the self and they all
manifest in their own way at their own
time
you know and when the breaks are off
then you you it's like that's that's
what's then always happening it's like
this beautiful balance
that's not like a perfect static balance
it's like you know like all the yogas
are perfectly balanced you know but it's
like this
it's like this beautiful wave you know
for each person and that's what's so
beautiful about your podcast right is
all these different individuals sharing
all these different like from all these
different angles of the wave or i've
always i've often seen it as this like
um spiral flame
you know like of this fractal where
we're all like we're all like
dancing together through this spiral
and um and that's the fractal of the
whole
spiritual personal development industry
we can call it that or the coaching
industry or the fitness industry the
nutrition industry the entrepreneur like
they're all these fractals of the same
one flame
you know where everyone is kind of just
like learning knowledge passing it down
learning knowledge passing it down
experiencing passing it on
and
yeah it's uh it's a nice image to
experience not just like conceptualize
but to be in yes
to participate in yes
i love that and every time that i tune
in to the essence of source and how it
expresses itself and dances with itself
plays with itself in this generation of
universes and then these earth's
orbiting stars where sentience wakes up
from its illusion of separation and lack
and sense of separate self
that
every time when i tune into that highest
sense of the essence of source
that the
spiral
as has been said in evolutionary
psychology as well as the mystics that
there is this spiral dynamical play and
i love how you talk about it like also a
flame
and also the direct experience of it
above everything
um and you can so clearly see that
because we came from a place that was
feeling loud it was feeling
separation and it was seeking freedom it
was seeking happiness seeking peace
seeking love
and it
shifted through these different programs
or through these different stages where
there was the entrepreneurial script
that was running and then there was the
script of i will meditate and then there
was the script of of i will understand
what nonduality is
and then there's finally there's just
this liberation of the seeking itself
because there is a moment-to-moment
deepest
experience of what nature is
and then it's so clear because there's
no more need to even run the
spirituality script or the non-duality
script
um
and there's no need to run the teacher
script either which is super important
and heavily forgotten
and then
there's a
there's such an effortlessness of the
freedom expressing itself like serving
the spiral
wherever it's at
so
and and that's just like that's the
bounciness and that's the freedom and
the love
um and never for
the
amplification of self-image the
proliferation of that but it's always
for other self and always for that hall
of mirrors style experience that
fractal-like uh dance and always for the
other self always for their awakening
which is you um appearing like another
self
and
and that's
i've
out of everything that i've been able to
call freedom
is is really that like more than
anything it's a simultaneity of it all
and then also the ability to
to serve myself waking up to myself
yeah there's
it's just it's so it's so rich
it's so
because that's the teach learn learn
teach of the one
um
[Music]
which arguably is the entire intention
of
creation yeah
yeah yeah just this endless sharing
and the sharing in all ways like
verbally energetically artistically
you know
there's so many ways to share and i feel
that
like you know what you were mentioning
before about the balancing out like you
know basic needs and everyone kind of
has moved beyond these
lack based the original lack you know
they've uprooted that original lack
and then operating that original lack
like what else is there to do but
they're but but creativity but like a
creative flow of
artistry and expression and connection
and play and
you know like that's there isn't really
much else and then you know within that
there's service but the service is of
very much this pure innocent creativity
and
i i've noticed this a lot too in this
kind of paradigm of the world we're in
right now where you know there's a lot
of changes happening people have all
these ideas about where the world's
gonna head and you know splitting or
these different things and
but but if if you're realizing yourself
as the space between everything
then there isn't
like this set way that the world is
going to end up because of course what's
the world for one but specifically like
you're already that wherever you are so
whether you're like in some off-grid
community or whether you're in this the
depth of the city or
you know you're it's it's it's you're
the space in between it all and
but and and with that that's the kind of
new frequency range we could say that
we're all kind of tuning to
that it's it's like the other aspects of
lack that perpetuate
all the the density within around that
space kind of just almost doesn't become
perceivable anymore
you know and and um i've noticed this a
lot uh even just entertaining things
like gift economy energies or being
nomadic kind of like you guys or you
know like just like the combinations of
these different ways to engage the
physical world but
especially the summer i was spending a
lot of time just with community and in
these different like community pockets
people have land or out of the city in
the city
and it's just like everywhere you go
you're just met with the same frequency
it doesn't matter where you are it
doesn't matter you're in the depth of
the city or outside you're just always
met with the same frequency and the
creative um
beauty that just emerges within all that
is just endless there's no there's
literally no end you know
and uh
and that's that's that's what i feel
we're all continually acclimatizing to
and funny enough like you were saying
the importance of community i think it's
it's yeah so vital because so much for
the spiritual journey is spent alone
uh or in solitude or in the
the inner workings and
and yet it's truly within this plane of
this human body the truth is we are just
simply seeking intimacy you know the
intimacy of itself
source with other
perceived other and and
kind of dancing with that intimacy which
you know we could say is creative energy
or you know whatever but
but i noticed that in dry fasting states
too like yeah i can i can drive a while
i was just about to head into this topic
so yeah
i love
how
we
are both so passionate about
fasting
so i'm already fasted for a day right
now which is a constant
process for me
at least once every couple of weeks to
at least fast for a day sometimes up to
three days
usually water
is what i'm fasting with
and then one longer fast
usually every maybe six months or a year
of like up to five days water have not
done no water yet
and the vibrancy of everything that
we're talking about being embodied is
amplified when we fast
everything we've been talking about is
amplified when we fast
and just most simply speaking it's
because you're not
your bodily energy your metabolism is
not focused on the digestion of food
but rather it's focused on whatever
energetically the imagination the focus
is dedicated to the attention is
dedicated to
and so
that's where it's easier to be in
samadhi
it's easier to be in yourself
it's easier to
be
relaxed and it's
easier to not get caught by a sensation
and then driven into a sense of
self-image
and
i feel really good about this subject
together and i feel like we may even do
a
a fast together
perhaps even a dry fast and then
document it
um where we talk maybe on um the first
day
at the end and then maybe at the end of
the third day and at the end of the
fifth day or something like that
and
tune into that experience together and
podcast about it as we do it and i feel
like that could be also really
instrumental as a catalyst for many of
you
because it can sometimes be a big
oh no i don't know about not eating
um
oh no i don't know about not drinking
and we would like to just really
demystify that um and to make it really
practical and really relatable
and also at the same time to
mystify in terms of mysticism it for you
which is your feeling of god within
okay so
um
how how tell us about the history of
your fasting
um your
cadence or your rhythm with it
um what arises for you and also the
segway that you were also on
um yeah well yeah that's a great way of
describing it i mean i like the flow
that you have you know the balanced um
approach to not doing it you know too
much uh because i feel like there can be
times where it becomes another mechanism
of we could say like list chasing you
know i often speak to that about a lot
of practices like intense breath work
fasting psychedelic work they all can be
kind of this chasing of a rainbow and
often a chasing of higher frequency or
movement into higher chakras
particularly and um that can be actually
quite dangerous you know i remember
times in my initial periods where that
was like a constant focus
stemming from that original lack you
know that deep intense seeking energy
that wants to like get to some place get
to some place and it's almost like this
the image i get is almost like a
like a graph like some sort of like
fractal graph that's like
it's like shooting and then collapsing
and shooting because it's the foundation
isn't there you know
so it's really important that you know
with with people who are embarking on
well really any practice but
particularly fasting is there is that
balance and there is an approach where
nothing needs to be too much of a push
i feel
i mean it's why buddha was always so big
on the middle way and so many other
teachers because they went to the
extremes and they realized that didn't
have anything for you there you know
um
and that's my approach with
communicating with with
with the fasting and it's still an
experimentation for me but
um you know this journey has been almost
10 years now where
like in conjunction with my initial
awakenings at 16 when i started like
trying to eat better eat like healthy
chicken salads or something some fitness
diet you know everything in my journey
of upgrades in terms of frequency or in
terms of
um some sort of assimilation of higher
consciousness
there was a simultaneous uh lightning in
the body that was occurring right and
and this is not just the physical aspect
but all layers of self because
there's a beautiful quote and i've kind
of expanded on it but there's a
beautiful quote by one of my old mentors
his name's arnold eric and
his quote was all disease is
constipation
and that has stuck so much with me and i
view it more as physical constipation
physical toxicity
rigid mental patterns you know
stuck emotions unprocessed shadow
unprocessed emotional energy and
energetic uh build up or miasmic buildup
you call it
and so all layers of that
are responsible for all forms of disease
and suffering in my view you know like
coming from that original lack because
because we have that constipation in us
we believe there's something wrong with
us and then we go about our seeking and
going about our are running towards some
some moment some promised land that
never really gives what what we you know
um thought we were going to get
so each of this you know over the period
of time where i went you know it's a
vegetarian and i went to vegan then i
went raw vegan then i went fruitarian
and in this time starting to do you know
small little juice cleanses or you know
colon cleanses or different fasts and
things and
and every time starting to notice like
holy crap like i'm doing these juice
guns and all the stuff is coming out of
me like where is this coming from you
know like this stank ass like crap you
know like um
really not not stuff that
should be anywhere in the body
so that was a big eye-opener just on the
physical level because i had dealt with
so many physical issues in my life you
know like i was a really sick kid i was
always the doctor you know it was all
these complications and
and so you know
the the process of awakening for me is
just like that the full spectrum
approach you know and the body is so
vital like we the clean the cleanliness
of the temple is is certainly going to
support us in being able to be in more
of a a balanced space and we could say
maybe it's more important as a
preparation
for realization on some level um because
of course when you start to tap into
that through compassion and love you you
know you can transmute a lot of things
and there's a lot of great masters in
the past who didn't really give a [ __ ]
about their body that much you know so i
do understand that that that um
side of things you know like smoking
cigarettes all day or even like whatever
and because you're in such a you know
peaceful space it's almost like the
frequency is kind of like dissolving a
lot of these elements
but you know some of these masters still
died of cancer and things like this too
so for me i'm like well
that doesn't really feel resident for me
like i feel like i can take my body much
farther than you know that type of
approach to things right and
so we're in a different time now and and
that's where the fasting really um has
has given me unity to
um
heal you know really heal like
specifically just like if we're looking
at physical like all the ailments i've
faced
the acne or the back issues or the
the mental health you know brain all
kinds of brain stuff and
um
you know everything like just so many
things you know like i have so many
lists of things that i've i've been
through and
um so fasting was the doorway to that
and in conjunction um and i guess the
way i approach it the way i teach it is
you know dry fasting yes certainly for
most is quite the stretch um but in my
view it's like the most representative
of the natural state
um because
i always had an intuition that you know
consumption maybe maybe the the the
the chewing of the apple maybe it's a
figurative story but in the garden of
eden maybe that was actually way more
literal
in regards to the fall of grace right
and so when we look at like kalonic
teachings you know they're they're quite
clear on the fact that you know many
many many many many years ago we were
originally brethren beings
and we were self-sustained from within
us because we we had the correct
alignment within our brain within our
dna to be able to sustain ourselves
but that's very much changed and i
certainly don't recommend people
prehearing or anything like that
but
i i do not only do i see it as a
possibility but i see it as
potentially a natural progression maybe
not in this lifetime for some but you
know it's even just small little bits of
a taste of like a 36 hour dry fest where
nothing is coming in you know not even a
drop of water not even brushing your
teeth
and you're starting to now feel this you
know you may go through a little initial
okay the emotions start to come up or
the mind starts freaking or you know but
after a bit of practice with that all of
a sudden you start to feel this natural
like um like emanation you know like
this this this very subtle peacefulness
and it's like the cells all the cells
just kind of calm down you know like you
start to tune into the natural
compassion that's like inherently built
in with you because because when you're
fast it's like you're naturally more
gentle you speak more gently you know
like
it's just
it's there
right so
so my flow you know i went through many
phases i i was really into the
fruitarian thing for a while whereas
going on extended fruit diets and that
was a big change because
in my experience even if someone doesn't
get into any fasting if the whole world
changed about 60 to 70 high water
high water containing fruits and
vegetables in in primarily raw form i i
view like a good portion of the disease
in the planet would be eradicated you
know just from that simple shift alone
um and that's generally where i start
with people i'm just like literally just
start with that sixty percent of your
diet
high uh water foods you know like then
eat whatever else you want you wanna eat
meat you wanna do that like do whatever
you want but if you just start to open
up that and you start to hydrate in a
new way
um
that can be a huge step right um and
then i got into juice fast i did a 39
and a half day juice fast i did many 10
days you know i did
all kinds of little fasts in between the
juices i'm sure everybody just to make
sure everybody heard you clearly um 39
and a half day
39.5
day juice fast
yeah yeah and that one that one was so
effortless actually because i had
prepped for so long i was i was already
you know in a natural kind of fruitarian
type of what
space um
i guess i don't really label myself as
any form of eating but if there was one
that feels most resonant it's called
it comes from the essene tradition his
esoteric teachings of jesus
and it's called a compassionate
fruitarianism which is essentially
it's fruitarianism but it extends into
nuts seeds sprouted grains and also even
animal products because it's just like a
raw milk
raw goat milk raw cheese
because all of these things are just
provided for without you needing to kill
an animal or even a plant right because
you can still like kill a carrot and you
know they actually have faces sometimes
you can tune into that so
the compassionate protagonism was this
model that was that was you know
essentially one of the core approaches
in that time
that was not you're not killing anything
but it was it's beyond what we typically
view as precarious you know which is
just like fruit i guess
but that's that's probably most accurate
but i don't exclusively stay there you
know i when i went on that juice cleanse
i cleared out so much plaque so plaque
is like a buildup of old fecal matter
that could be in there for 10 20 30
years right
whatever age
um so that's like a tar that starts to
come out of you so i had multiple feet
of that coming out of me over that that
period of time
mixed with all kinds of other things
and so that was a big eye-opener because
you know i don't know like if you
just leave food in your fridge for a
month
you know what i mean uh we usually have
to take it out after a month now think
about your your body being a 38 degree
sauna
where you have old food in your body
and it's been there for 20 years like if
the idea that people you know we're so
confused as to the origin of all these
diseases we have all these separate
diagnosis and specialists for the left
toe and the right finger and this and
that and like but really it's all coming
from the same main core and that's a lot
of it meaning we haven't eliminated
properly the stuff we've consumed
because we've been so addicted
consumption in all forms
right and i i view that primarily being
the connection of food and emotion or
food and love because the moment we come
out of the womb my old uh
this old chronic breatharian teacher
taught me this she was speaking about
the idea of her name's flet lana and she
was speaking about how the moment you
come out of the womb what do you get you
get the breast any any noise you're
making you get the breast when you're a
good boy or a good girl you get you get
the breast you get the food
you know when you're bad maybe you get a
not so tasty food you know every emotion
essentially is tied to
the consumption of food right social
gatherings you know family gatherings
and all of it
so
so it's a beautiful thing and i love
eating people and i love you know when
i'm eating i absolutely love eating i'm
like i just adore it i have been more
i've become more of a foodie since i've
been in this right yeah but when i'm
fasting i absolutely i love the fasting
and i think that's the biggest most
important principle to remember is it's
not about just becoming as batharian or
you know
you know shunning food it's just back to
that divine love that devotional yes
energy exactly hardcore remembering
moment to moment
yeah
that's it i i feel like um it's one of
the most accessible also mainstream
uh gateways
uh to waking up
um is fasting along with the breath
and self-inquiry
um
but
fasting
is
like a simple way to just say it would
be like
[ __ ] you think you you think you can
you think you're gonna die from not
eating for a day
you you think you think that
you think that you're gonna
go an entire 80-year life
without spending one day completely
fasted
like
are you [ __ ] like you can't do that
like
really
or you can't go two days without eating
you think you're gonna die
like
so
um i felt a similar energy six years ago
when i did my first 10 david pastrana
meditation retreat like a lot of the
energy was just like
i can sit down for 10 straight days and
shut the [ __ ] up i don't have to talk
for 10 straight days i would love to see
what happens when i shut up for 10
straight days and what happens like i
would love to the same thing's true with
fasting you know
just be excited or exhilarated or
thrilled by what will happen when you
uh break your chain of addiction to
eating for a day
and so that's one of my favorite
approaches to it and i see it as a huge
gateway for for mainstream waking up
and then also another thing that you
said that i think is just so potent and
so
scientifically on point because
for the longest time we've been talking
about now the gut
the gastrointestinal tract having
so much being like a second brain
and
there's so
much
age
also billion year intelligence that's
located there
because we're talking about all of these
uh bacteria
and so many other
parts to the
uh biological kingdoms that are billions
of years old that
we're in a symbiotic relationship with
that are housed here in our on our gut
and
this as you describe in this
40-day
juice cleanse
that
to me it appears like where
in the
gi
tract you're gonna have especially like
in the in the small intestine
you're gonna have a
you have these villi
and they're they're basically these
nutrient absorbers that line the gut
like this and there's tons and tons and
tons of them
and so as as the
as the food
moves through
after it's already been
um
significantly broken down by
the stomach acid
um
that
there's an absorption that happens by
these villi into your into your body
and i feel like what you're talking
about is that over time especially with
zero
cleanses
that there's a
a sludginess
that builds up in those
in those villi like in these pockets and
around them
and what the water or the juice
cleanses do
is that they provide a
de-sludgification whereas the hard food
they
further and further add and add and yeah
some of it can slide out but then more
of it gets stuck and some of it slides
out more of it and then there's some
that's stuck from five years ago or 10
years ago has just been built up
um
is that also how you see it also from
that scientific
side of the coin
yeah yeah that's a great way of
describing it you know there's uh
sometimes as well too like the
intestinal tract you know it's like a
tube and then sometimes that stuff
builds up and actually creates like a
secondary pocket
right
where because that's a lot of like
doctors you know they put cameras up
there and they're like oh well there's
no plaque where is it i'm like think
about it you know these the gi tracts
almost 30 feet long it's like a
two-story house of course there's going
to be stuff all in there and all the
different crevices right and
so yeah that's a really good way of um
describing it and you know so we have
you know mucoid plaque you have what's
called a biofilm which is like yes
sludgy like
film mucousy type membrane that starts
to come out um
acids parasites worms there's all kinds
of worms and [ __ ] i've seen come out of
people myself sometimes even sneeze it
out it's coming out of your brain
because the gi tract is the first avenue
right including of the liver and then
kind of like the kidneys but then you
also have the lymphatic system and in
the western medical system the the
obsession is with blood blood blood
blood blood blood
blood right and that's why they can
never find and that's so so too much
difficulty diagnosing people a lot of
times because
the blood is not generally the issue
the the over acidity in the lymphatic
system which is the other liquid system
which is the elimination channels of our
body that's what's blocked up and that's
blocked up through the kidneys blocked
up through the gi tract our skin is
heavily like in like kind of just
clogged right
so
that's really the core of where we're
gonna find the the original issue it's
like if you didn't flush your toilet for
20 years i mean your whole house would
get destroyed you know
so
um
so you know the juice fast and sometimes
the water fast that helps a lot with
clearing up the colon and it's really
important and my programs at least that
i put out like they focus on that
because
that's for most people that's you have
to start there you know um because if
you start detoxing everything else then
you start re-toxifying yourself you know
because your everything's blocked up
including your gi tract so it all starts
to
right so that's the first step before
you get into dry fasting but dry fasting
is like exponentially
um
more of an efficient healer because in
dry fasting you basically turn your body
into an internal inferno right your body
starts going through its glycogen stores
first
and then once it gets through glycogen
stores it goes into autophagy and that's
where the lysosomes in your cells which
are like the furnaces they start eating
all the dead sick or the unhealthy sick
cancerous and the fat cells
and they start breaking them down
um removing that waste and then
rehydrating yourself with that living
water that's within those cells so it's
funny enough you actually don't feel
that dehydrated oh my gosh that's how
the functionality works so autophagy as
diseased cells are destroyed the body
will then nourish itself with the water
from the diseased cells
that's so interesting i was always
wondering how the body would have like a
hydrative component um during that time
because the burning of glucose for
energy and then burning of
fat for energy is so common people
recognize ketosis when they drop into
that
[Music]
but in terms of maintaining a stable
sense of being hydrated and not thirsty
for even a period of um
what do
what it's uh
the the the
the mantra that we've been programmed
with is three minutes without air three
days without water three weeks without
food it's a mantra
um
yeah
and yeah well it's yeah
yeah that's funny
yeah it's and it's it's become uh
like aubrey de gray who we've had on the
show several times talks about aging
like a trance like it's a pro aging
trance like that it's totally normal to
get cancer and die
um now we should just be totally
normalize that but that's just the
chance that we've transferred ourselves
with rather than feeling into well
actually [ __ ] i'm going to live until
i'm 120 or 150. um and the way that i'm
going to do that is by
is by tuning into
the way that cells become diseased and
eradicating um any diseased components
within cells as they arise
and
one of the greatest ways to do that
through all of the natural past that
we've studied is through fasting it's so
good so okay so um keep hitting us with
where you were at on the how the body uh
continues hydrating itself so so
interesting during water fast during
water fasting
yeah well the the dry um yes or the dry
stuff yeah it's called my fasting yep
okay yeah no no food no water and um
you know i've i've learned from
individuals that are more breatharian
based so they're not even using the term
fasting they just they just say living
in the natural state or the chronic
state right where they're they're
focused on um how to just continue it as
a lifestyle which i think you know for
99 people it's not going to be so that's
totally fine but even just
a you know extended drawing when when
there's a preparation for it that that
literally could be like
years worth of healing you know i'm
actually starting to create like a
calculation of comparison between dry to
water to fruit to juice
it's kind of difficult to do but it's
it's a bit exponential so
what i understand is like a seven day
dry could equal to about 40 days water
maybe 50 days juice 60 days juice you
know 12 day dry that's going to be like
something like 67 days water 100 120
days juice you know so like it's like
exponential the speed and
yeah that's right okay so
for every
day
of
let's say
uh
dry fasting
is
let's say
um maybe
correct me if i'm wrong maybe two
two or three days of
water fasting which one day of dry
fasting is equivalent to maybe four or
five days of juice fasting something
along those lines
i'd say a bit more even like five to six
days five to seven days water and then
you know eight to nine maybe a juice i'm
still kind of feeling into this one one
day of dry yeah
yeah
is equivalent to almost a week of
of water fasting or juice fasting
i think it'll be more prevalent once you
get over the
autophagy threshold right because around
36 48 hours sometimes three days it may
tank
so
when you're speaking under three days
the effects are going to be beautiful
but but not like yeah you know they're
interesting so you really have to you
really have to get over the autophagy
threshold especially in the dry fast to
really begin seeing what you're talking
about so once you get over three days or
so of dry fasting then you'll feel these
like compounding benefits that will feel
like you've been juice fasting for two
weeks or something
correct yeah yeah that's that's how i've
experienced it i mean like on this last
protocol that i did i didn't make it the
whole way but it's it's essentially 11
days so i did about 10 and um
you know uh that comes from a doctor
named dr philinov sergey filanov from
russia they're big on the dry fasting
and chronic living and stuff so he has a
clinic where he runs people through this
11 12 day protocol
and he's kind of got it down to like a
real specific science and um you know
they've had the most remarkable healings
happen from everything you could pretty
much think of
and there's basically two main
acid crisises or releases that happen
the first one is from day around four to
six and the second one is from eight to
ten ish
and i experienced both of those and
they're quite something i mean i was
pretty prepared but even still you know
and you know so
so you can really because because
the vision i had with the dry is just
this idea that almost it's like all the
sludge from every crevice of your body
you know like your joints your muscles
your brain like that's what's being
pulled out it's not just the gi tract
anymore and
and that's basically what i felt like i
experienced because you know i'm i'm
about four days after the breaking i'm
still on liquids and men i'm still
purging all kinds of stuff and it's not
so much solid without getting too much
detail but
just acid waste that's the the best way
i could describe it you know and for me
i feel like that's just coming from
everywhere like every crevice of my body
where that has potentially been stored i
don't i don't know really you know i'm
still uncovering it um so i still feel
like a baby in it all but
um
but yeah so
you know the dry it's no joke i mean it
but it's definitely it's very efficient
and
and you know if people you know use for
me to go just doing intermittent that
intermittent dry fasting was the biggest
one of the biggest noticeable shifts on
my path when it comes to this type of
healing right like
you know we dry fast every night people
say they don't drive fast you drive fast
every night that's what sleeping is it's
dry fasting so if you just extend that
you know 12 to 20 hours daily
intermittent dry fasting
and then you have you have that open
window four to 12 hours of eating you
know
for me it was like a lot of fruits and
quinoas and some cooked veggies or
something different phases right
that in itself could just be a huge step
you know and then you get used to that
maybe that's a year for you maybe that's
a while and then then you maybe do like
a 36 hour or 20 you know 48 hours
something like this and you keep kind of
building up and that's how that's how i
view it now like
it's better to just keep building over
time there's no unless you're in a real
chronic state right where there's a real
serious situation and
we won't get into that too much but i
mean that's that's generally where you
don't really have much time to waste you
know
um but it doesn't have to be dry you
could do other forms and things that are
a bit more of a useful graceful you know
step i guess
so yeah
i love how you described it like a
pulling out of all sludge
and yeah of all toxicity that was great
and then another point that i
wanted to share with especially
mainstream
is that
leveraging this as a gateway is also
very powerful for you saving a fuckload
of time which is also fascinating
um you have no idea how many hours
you spend
on
the acquiring of food
um the eating of food
the cleaning up of food um the money
that's spent on food
and
the
energy fluctuation also is huge
so
um
imagine like you're in a you're in a
work sprint on something from nine until
noon and then at noon to one
you go and you get lunch
but it's never just you know spending 20
bucks and getting food and then eating
it
but it's also
the fact that then that food creates a
spike
in your glucose
and
then you have a
your body your metabolism it has to
forcibly
generate
insulin to be able to deliver that
glucose to it the cells
so you're forcing your body into
metabolic processes to
deal with your spike of glucose and
that's why people feel what's called
that like afternoon siesta um
you know and
um
what a great way to
um train oneself
but then to
not have a one to two to three o'clock
like murpiness to your energy but rather
from 12 to one to two to three all of
that time you're still rolling you're
still fueled whether you're out whether
you're out in nature or you're in a
workflow or you're reading a book or
you're talking to a friend or you're
jumping between different meetings or
whatever it is
like
there's so much power in the amount of
time and energy that's saved um also um
and where we can reallocate that
and i feel like that's another really
crucial point for mainstream um
yeah and also the element that because
the most most most individual's idea is
that well you know my energy comes from
food and liquids right but if we really
break that down
food and liquid is only one avenue to
where we we sustain our energy right
like what happens when you're inside for
too long and then you go outside and you
get in the sun and you feel like the
exuberance and the energy that fuels you
up from the sun you know or you go you
go on a run or a walk or you work out
you're moving the breath you're doing
some breath work again all this energy
from the breath
bare feet on the soil you know rolling
around in the grass like being in in the
green
once again
more energy um you know intimate
connections like social connections like
creative movement if you're in like a a
truly creative like pure like
communication you'll feel energized
after not drained
you know so there's so many more ways
that we we are fueled by energy like let
alone just the source of god itself like
just the the nature of of who we
actually are is
perpetuating like the sun
you know it's just like this sun-like
radiance from within so
when you when you go into a dry or
something like this you may have to go
through these initial layers of
purification and withdrawal and low
energy and so there's a trusting in the
body that happens there you know sleep
when you're tired you know all that kind
of stuff
but in truth you start to really see
actually how much energy you have
you know like i in the summer i was dry
passing all the time i was still doing
30k bike rides i was driving all around
you know connecting with people and the
energy is just there um
and then when i want to eat i want to
eat and then i eat and it's and it
doesn't have to be any sort of dogmatic
approach with it um and also like i'll
reiterate the importance of the
emotional work the the ice you know i
call it shadow work or trauma work
because again the the bliss chasing
is what caught is generally caused by a
lack of integration of shadow in my view
you know it's like a it's like a running
to somewhere without integrating the
you know the darkest shittiest whatever
aspects of you that you have to take a
look at um
and i feel like those two in particular
in conjunction is really what brings a
true sense of grounding because i don't
i don't define grounding as feeling
dense i feel i view grounding as
an embodiment of our you know
fullest self in this present moment
awareness you know
um
and so
so because people bring that up a lot
like oh you know you're going to feel
lofty and yeah i went through a lot of
phases where i was fasting i felt very
lofty in that but nowadays i mean i feel
more grounded than ever and
you know it's because it's
we've talked about so many topics today
and i feel like that's the point it's
like it's not just one thing you know
it's it's this full spectrum approach
and we'll always be kind of like brought
back into balance if we go too far in
one
direction or get attached to one idea or
something you know
so yeah
and another important
scientific way to understand it is that
there's a higher
atp or adenosine triphosphate
density in fat than there is in glucose
so you're feeling more energy
so in the citric acid cycle or the krebs
cycle you're actually feeling more
energy when you're burning fat than you
are when you're burning glucose glucose
is a horrible source of energy in
comparison to fat fat is an incredible
powerful
longer burning much more cleaner burning
source of energy and this is exactly
what people talk about when they
eat uh avocado or whatever rather than
um
like eating a
greasy burger or whatever it is um
that you can feel why can you feel a
difference between when you eat an
avocado and how much like how like light
like that feels and how like slow
burning and like nice that feels for
like even four hours you can get by on
an avocado
versus when you eat that at that burger
and that bread like you're you're just
like
and like it just feels so draining on
your energy levels um
and so
it's it's another really good thing to
tune into ketosis and to tune into um
what will
happen when i get over the
um the ghrelin which is the the hormone
that's secreted for hunger when i get
over those little ghrelin spikes that
i've been conditioned and trained to be
secreted every however many four to six
hours when i get over those little
ghrelin
secretions then what happens is i'm in
ketosis and i feel more and more of that
steady higher energy burn and that um
less and less of the immediacy of
needing to respond to just the the
ghrelin
[Music]
and then there's another thing which is
the sovereignty there's so much
sovereignty and so much will and so much
choice
um that's
that's unfrozen from conditioning and
from patterns and is able to sort of
like take its divine creatorhood more
precisely um and you can just drive your
attention and your focus your
imagination your creativity will to
whatever so much more frictionlessly um
and
yeah so all of those things together are
you know just
a little bit
i'm so happy that we talked about it on
on the show but this is even just
like it's concept still for many of you
that haven't went a day without eating
get the direct experience of it more
than anything is go one day without
eating are you a little [ __ ] or can you
do it
because you can do it i know you can and
i'm talking to i'm talking to myself
right now because this is exactly
the same energy that you know a couple
of years ago was my
my feeling of like ah i can do it i can
i can do that um and so
i know that there are other selves that
are feeling that same way um and so
overcome any limiting beliefs you have
and
be able to get the direct experience of
what we're talking about and what it
feels like and then it's like a muscle
and you want to train it
and so who knows
maybe corey and i will do a
dry fast even together and do some
podcasts about it so um it'd be super
cool bro
yeah yeah yeah that would be cool yeah i
mean
it's yeah it's a pretty remarkable and
like you said such an easy practice for
people to access you know it's not
yeah it's like 24 hours three days you
know it's not really the end of the
world but you can't yeah and i think
that's what we we uproot like how crazy
the mind is you know like
like you know it's just this is a funny
thing but
um but yeah that'd be really cool that'd
be really cool
yeah bro mind is always craving always
craving and like uh we get great insight
into that craving process also from um
slowing down and fasting because
i remember one time i didn't eat refined
sugar for like almost a whole year um
it was while i was dating one of my
ex-girlfriends for
almost three years
and i remember her
her anger because she was like why don't
you eat desserts with me
and then i remember
like being in an elevator with someone
that was bringing freshly baked cookies
to some sort of event that we were
hosting
and i had never smelled refined sugar
before up until that point like
i just remember when only from fasting
from refined sugar for such a long time
did i realize like the addictive
craviness um
like the true addictive craviness to it
um
and then it's and then you know you
collapse the duality as well and you
enjoy some cookies and a brownie
uh and whatever the [ __ ] you want too
yep
yeah
yeah exactly exactly man i mean i
remember i had this uh event we did a
convention or something in montreal and
uh we were i was basically dry faster
the whole weekend and
um i had coconut water that that evening
but other than that you know we were
doing 12 hour days and just you know all
out very social and then at the end i
wanted to treat the whole team to a meal
and we went to this vegan spot and they
have this amazing like you know indian
it's like an indian family that runs it
and man like i never eaten something
with such like i was crying in the meal
like i i was eating it was like
everything was alive you know like every
rice was alive like it was like speaking
to me it was
i'll never forget it i'll never forget
it and it was just a perfect example of
you know like
just when you're in when there's a
natural like fluidity with the
experience of whether eating whether
you're fasting or doing this and not the
dogmas of things then
it's god it's it's it
yeah
i would love to hear
from
you guys also
about
if you would enjoy
or like to see
us do a dry fast together and document
it
and
[Music]
how often you would like to see us do
the episodes
right now we're feeling like maybe at
the end of day one at the end of day
three at the end of day five so rhythm
like that so let us know what you feel
um
and
also um i'm feeling really good even
about rapping now i feel like we've
covered
so much bro do you feel good you feel
content like complete yeah cool yeah
it's been great man it's been really
great i mean it is yeah spontaneity you
know just let it flow and uh yeah it's
beautiful i really appreciate you and
this platform you've developed
and everyone watching you know it's nice
yeah bro i i appreciate you tremendously
i appreciate our brotherhood a lot i
feel a lot of power together um i feel
like this is only
though i'm noticing less and less people
come on the show and because i'm
obviously self-selecting and that the
quality of the people that are coming on
the show is so much higher now in terms
of resonance with the nature
and with brotherhood like long-term
creating potential and it feels so good
that that's the case um and so i feel
like we could even not only do
um that
cool dry podcast
tripod thing oh my god dry fasting
podcasting um but i also feel like we
can even just like revisit every
like three months or whatever into
conversation together and just see where
each other are keep
keep it
rolling powerfully and
um
yeah and also so where is it best for um
people to fall besides instagram
instagram um corey's prolific on they're
posting all the time writing great posts
um sharing great content on there where
else would be another good place for
people and we'll link all this in the
bio
um yeah well i have a youtube channel
and i'm getting a bit more active on but
also my website ayp awaken your
potential or ayp dot life
um so yeah we can link that and um but
yeah instagram is a great place too so
yeah those are the places
sweet so instagram youtube
and ayp ayp.life
and those will be in the bio below um
and
thank you everybody for tuning in we
love you infinitely this was a dope
episode we hope you guys got a lot of
value alone um
and it's funny i'm looking at the camera
and i'm like seeing my other selves
watching right now and it's like so
[ __ ] trippy and there's no substances
involved except just natural state of
existence
um i love you i love me i love i
and thank you thank you for tuning in
um
like the video it helps algorithm also
comment below with your thoughts on the
episode
um
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
yet
and share the video also if it resonates
with other people that you feel like it
would make a profound impact on
and
check out the links in the bio to all
things
corey shake
and
that's all fam love you guys so much
thanks for tuning in i'll end the
recording and then you and i will stay
in the room together okay
okay
bye everyone